yes I make youtube videos laughs at
other people's memes and get money the
joke's on you I don't make any money
krysta videos get monitored him on it's
not a a a a a a a man ay ay ay ay ay ay
ay ay ay what up you poor people check
out my latest car that I bought that's
right pretty impressive I know what's
that in the back oh that's my mansion
that you could never afford that's right
I am so incredibly rich just kidding
haha you fell for that old meme this is
a green screen you can do all kinds of
things with these Hey look now I'm an
I'm an Indian ow just kidding Hey look
now I'm in Guatemala just kidding this
green screen is from El Gato I'm gonna
link them in your description if you
guys want to check them out this thing
is genius
if you ever had a green screen it is the
ugliest it looks amazing on videos like
it can really it can really amp up the
quality of your content and really put
yourself out there but if you ever use
the green screen it takes up your entire
space it looks ugly
it's wonky as how a lot of them are just
cheap and bad you need to light it
properly so you need to get all this
lining equipment with this baby I'm
saying this from the bottom of my heart
I'm he never been some more genuine
never been
this makes my life so much easier
you know I how I had that projector and
a like before I had this giant bar on my
ceiling and that was a projector that I
just painted green and I paid more for
that than this el gato thing so yeah if
you make videos check out el gato
obviously hashtag spawns but also very
nice now move on with the video Felix
please can you stop selling us things
you literally just made fun of us for
being poor you're right what means did
you submit this week oh I can't wait the
real reason why Sweden lost last night
posted five days ago Sweden lost because
Germany played well no Sweden lost
because they played badly no Sweden lost
because they didn't worship sliced up
before the match no Sweden lost because
Peter if I didn't include me bonus me
mean ladies bunk me
bonus meme is dead Jesus Christ wasted
to rub it in haha good rose Walmart the
pole brothers when the fight breaks down
in UK case I just start yelling Primark
up foot for kids to react to another
country I was gonna do a Swedish one but
just so it doesn't seem like I'm just
hating on all these countries but
there's nothing funny about Sweden they
just it's just in jokes that are unfunny
thank you bus driver very cool thank you
well done you know say what you want
about Trump but at least he thanks the
bus driver upload a few but Puetz to
actually show his YouTube analytics to
see how many nine year olds actually in
the army okay well let's just have a as
you can see here they're all nine year
olds the 13 year olds had had the lowest
attention span
select all squares containing a dick oh
that's the jokes around the sexist I see
this one it's the it's clearly the best
loss booga-booga sleepy sleepy she's
asleep now thank you for coming here
hypnosis hypnosis hypnotist which way is
the exit it's right over there okay guy
okay bye guys I'm leaving I lost in
another youniverse marinades this is the
fan art I get what the hell is say it's
like a hedgehog on my face it's not even
accurate women reveal two words they
love hearing during sex named river
board
fan coca-cola he stole your health
Disney he stole your childhood prawn hub
he stole your innocent pewdiepie he
stole your [ __ ] no I'm giving you
content it's different
definitely last night someone edited our
Wikipedia page to say it was our family
showed security at our show got into the
green room and had a beer with the boys
Sparra go you legend thanks for the
evening lads what an absolute mad lad
everybody slow internet again either my
son is downloading prawn or my daughter
is uploading
this me makes sense because it's how it
makes me like it's a whole upload it's
all upload it's all up though
well this seven-year-old video piece has
showed up in my wreck c'mon dead I guess
you guys are really are 9
congratulations that has 8 million views
that's crazy
well done good meme that was awesome
volt exponent faith rich stored in this
subreddit well done yeah I make youtube
videos laugh at other people's memes and
get money the joke's on you I don't make
any money because the videos get
monetary mono upvote ah accepting that
the new EU regulations bad memes adding
it overlay so the filter won't detect it
I mean literally million Brad have been
doing this for years whenever we have to
use audio we pitch it so he doesn't get
detected or we'll try and use it a
little shorter before it was like a
15-second thing this is literally it
this is how what we're already living
this meme this is not a meme it's life
honestly
so can I stop swearing please ask dear
Puetz
as i devoted for hen bees we can help
but notice you've been acting very
stressed in recent videos I think I
speak on behalf of the nine year old
army when I say suck it up you buckle
no one gives an F about you and your
depression
I never been more proud finally you guys
understand finally a heaven audience
that's not a bunch of little pictures
spend hours making these birds talk fake
its fake
okay it's not cringy if it's fake
don't waste my time with it damn you're
some solid edits in here it's simcha one
three five I've well done nihongo
namaste
boots they're still going have some the
thing is the more this goes on the more
inevitable it's going to be the fact
that I'll have to eat hit our bush on
pretty pie submissions 92% won't get
this joke
are you the nine percent apparently Matt
isn't your strongest suit this is
clearly a reception like the bird said I
can't cringe if it's fake don't waste my
time
whoever's doing the caption is killing
me realizes he couldn't come up with a
joke in time because he's not creative
and that he gets all his comedic credit
from his fans and editors hey you know
that is so this is the EU flag yep and
you know it's public domain yep
so making it a meme won't actually
change anything
that makes sense so stop making those
memes on July 5th we must only upload
pictures of the EU flags so they become
a meme and must ban themselves of oh my
godness is genius finally we'll fight
fire with fire
there will be no banning on memes on my
command that's right my can we get some
military audience
my fellow 9 year olds on July 5th we
will strengthen at dawn we will fight
them with their own weapons of machinery
copy copy strikes that's right copy
strikes your flax blast upload this
video if you want another look